-Welcome.
-Hi. Thanks for having me.
-You're very welcome.
I'm happy you're here.
So you play -- this is
a adaptation of a book
about someone who moves to
New York
and lands a job at
a very prestigious restaurant.
Had you waited tables before?
-I had not, no.
I'd worked in a pub,
when I was very underage.
Don't try that one at home.
It's different in England, guys.
-Yeah, how young -- how young
can you be
and work in a pub in England?
Is it like 11 or 12 years old?
-I feel like I'm gonna
get in trouble.
Maybe. I don't know.
It's not all Oliver Twist.
No. I was 16, but it was kind of
similar to Tess,
where I had experience with,
like, difficult customers
for example,
and I'd put food on a bar,
but I hadn't exactly
learned the disciplines.
-And you had to actually get
some skill training for this.
What was the hardest table
waiting skill for you to master?
-Like everything,
but the three-plate carry
is so difficult,
and it's a great skill
'cause I like food,
and now I can carry more food
from the kitchen to the sofa.
-So the is the three-plate
one, two, three?
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
So you put your -- you've got
one here, and then you use,
like, a sort of tripod, you've
got three points of contact.
-Sure.
-One here.
And you hold the third one here.
-Yeah. There you go.
Do you ever do the big tray
with a bunch of plates?
-Oh, no. No. No. No.
I'm not that advanced.
-Maybe season two.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah.
Now, this is
an adaptation of a book,
and obviously people who have
read it will watch the show,
and see if
it's a true adaptation.
You have done a lot of things
over your career
that have been book adaptations.
And, as a viewer, is it true
that you had issues
with some of
the "Harry Potter" films?
-Yeah, I did.
When I was really, really young.
I used to love --
I used to read it with my dad,
and I sat there on the sofa
when the first film came out,
and I followed it page by page,
and I got like
three paragraphs in,
and had a mental breakdown.
[ Laughter ]
Because I couldn't understand
why they would do that.
Now I'm older and wiser,
and I get it now,
and yeah, it's hard to do
something that's well-loved.
-This is in the -- You moved to
New York for this?
-Kind of, yeah.
-And do you have a different
experience now
when you go to restaurants,
when you look at actual people
who are doing the job?
-I do, yeah. I don't --
I'm, like, creepily
staring at people,
like, trying to figure out
the dynamics.
Like, who is friends with who,
and, like, who just messed up?
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
To them,
you look like a weird sadist.
-Oh yeah. Absolutely.
I'm, like, doing my own
three-plate carry.
They're like,
"What's she's doing?"
Yeah. No, for sure.
-You went --
You have a tattoo --
You have tattoos in real life,
a tattoo in the show.
You get a tattoo in the show
that you actually went
method for.
-Yeah, I did.
-So when we see you getting
a tattoo in the show,
that is an actual tattoo?
-Yeah, well, you don't see me
getting it done on the show.
-Okay, got you.
-When I did my screen test,
I had these tattoos,
and they were like,
"You've got to cover those up
if you want to get the job,"
and I was like,
"Fine, whatever."
Episode three comes along,
and they've written in, like,
Tess has a tattoo,
and I'm like,
"I'm just gonna go get it."
And the producer is like, "No."
[ Laughter ]
"You're not gonna do that."
So I came into work, and I got
it, and I was with my mum.
She came to visit me
in New York that week,
and so she, like, sat next
to me. She's like --
She'd been against me
getting tattoos for, like,
all 21 years of my life,
but suddenly she's like,
"I'm gonna get one too."
And now I can't stop her.
-Oh, no.
-She has so many.
She won't stop.
It's like she's addicted
to the ink.
[ Laughter ]
-This is one of
those weird cases
where the child is a terrible
influence on the parent.
[ Laughter ]
-I think so, yeah.
-Yeah. Now you're gonna start
having to worry about
who she's hanging out with,
what time she gets home.
-I know.
-Is this a picture of
the tattoo that you --
-Yeah. These are the matching
tattoos we got.
-See, that's really nice.
And they're not too bad
of all the tattoos
you could have gotten.
-Yeah.
-And as moms go,
I think it's very classy.
-Yeah, she is a cool mom.
She's badass. She's cool.
-Yeah, no -- I -- look,
that's official at this point.
Now, I hope my mom is watching
because you've let me down.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, thank you so much
for being here.
I really appreciate it.